[Musique]
les sénateurs agissent
comment améliorer l'accès aux soins
6 millions de Français dont 600 000 sont
en affection de longue durée n'ont pas
de médecins traitant face à ce constat
l'accès aux professionnels de santé
apparaît comme un enjeu majeur jeudi 6
avril 2023 la commission mixte paritaire
réunissant cette députée et cette
sénateur est parvenu à un accord sur la
proposition de loi portant amélioration
de l'accès aux soins les sénateurs ont
défendu sur ce texte une approche
équilibrée s'articulant autour de deux
axes revoir l'organisation du parcours
de soins des patients et permettre une
extension des champs de compétences des
professionnels de santé
le texte adopté reprend très largement
les modifications apportées par le Sénat
tout d'abord le compromis valide la
suppression des dispositions relatives à
l'engagement territorial des médecins
celle-ci avait été écartée par la
commission des affaires sociales du
Sénat aux motifs interférés avec les
négociations en cours de la nouvelle
convention médicale et contribuer à un
dégrader le climat de plus le texte
pérennise la compétence des préparateurs
en pharmacie pour administrer des
vaccins conformément aux souhaits des
sénateurs
le Sénat a également cherché à éviter
l'inertie du gouvernement pour
l'autorisation des tests rapides
d'orientation diagnostic innovants le
texte issu de la CMP contrat ainsi le
pouvoir réglementaire à publier
annuellement la liste de ces tests
pouvant être utilisés par les
professionnels de santé enfin le Sénat
avait estimé que l'accès direct aux
infirmiers en pratique avancées ainsi
qu'aux masseur kinésithérapeute devait
s'appliquer dans le cadre d'une relation
de confiance entre professionnels
médicaux et paramédicaux il l'avait donc
réservé aux structures d'exercices
coordonnées les mieux intégrés
partageant une patientèle commune
la solution portée par le Sénat et
retenue dans le compromis constitue une
voie raisonnable pour apaiser les
tensions entre professionnels de santé
dans l'intérêt des patients l'accès
direct est ainsi réservé aux
professionnels exerçants au sein d'une
structure de soins coordonnés par
exemple au sein d'une maison de santé
pluridisciplinaire d'un centre de santé
ou d'une équipe de soins primaires ou
spécialisés
l'expérimentation d'un accès direct en
communauté professionnelle territoriale
de santé pour 5 ans et dans 6
départements dont deux d'outre-mer devra
permettre d'en évaluer les effets avant
toute nouvelle évolution législative
pour en savoir plus consultez le site
Internet du Sénat
[Musique]